هذه المره من الجانب الاخر لرمضان من
موسكو مع الزميله عبد الجواد الرشد هناك
تستقبل مساجد المدينه خلال شهر رمضان
المبارك عددا من الصائمين على موائد
الرحمن ضمن خيانه شيد خصيصا لهذا الغرض
على كل حال يسعى القائمون ايضا على هذه
الخيام لدمج ثقافه البلاد مع طقوس الشهر
الفضيل ومن موسكو ينورنا مراسل صباح
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا
بك يسعد مساك رمضان كريم كل عام وانت بالف
خير يا عبد الجواد نقول لنا الطقوس
الرمضانيه من موسكو
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير سهام مساء الخير نادين كل عام
وانتم بالف خير ورمضان كريم انا الان اقف
في احد موائد الرحمن في العاصمه موسكو
المتواضعه يعني في احد باحات المساجد
يعنيثا ابتعد قليلا باعتبار ان اسطوره هي
سيد الموقف اليوم يعني عدد الاشخاص
المتواجدون الان في هذه الباحه يصل الى
قرابه 500 شخص طبعا نلاحظ بان المجتمع
الروسي يدخل العادات والتقاليد ضمن
الاحتفالات حتى في الخيم الرمضانيه لذلك
طبعا اليوم هو يوم الطفل الموهوب ولذلك
نلاحظ وجود عدد كبير من الاطفال طبعا في
هذه الزاويه سهام نلاحظ بانهم اقاموا ركنا
لتلقي زكاه الفطر وهي طبعا باللغه الروسيه
كلمه زكاه حاضره هنا اما على الجانب الاخر
سهام ونادين فنلاحظ بان الاطفال طبعا
عندما تم دعوتهم الى هذه الفعاليه قاموا
بالتحضير ويعني وعمل
يعني من من روحه الطفوله نلاحظ بانه مجسم
للكعبه المشرفه او لمسجد قل شريف في
العاصمه التتريه هذا المشهد طبعا داخل
الخيمه لكن اسمحوا لي بثواني معدوده ان
نرى كيف يبدو المشهد خارج هذه الخيمه طبعا
هي اعداد كبيره من الناس يصل عددها الى
قرابه الف شخص تقريبا يحضرون الى هنا بشكل
يومي لتناول وجبه الافطار وهذا هو مسجد
المدينه طبعا في المنطقه الغربيه لمدينه
المشهد فعلا رمضاني في امتياز من وسط
العاصمه الروسيه هذا العام ايضا في موسكو
عبد الجواد جاء الربيع مبكر يعني درجات
حراره في المدينه اليوم تصل حوالي 8 درجات
مئويه بينما اذا قرناها في السابق
بالسنوات سابقه كانت تكون 22 درجه تحت
الصفر فكيف هي الاجواء مع كل هذا التغيير
اليوم
[موسيقى]
نادين يعني عندما ناقشنا هذه الفكره معكم
اليوم لعرضها في مساء العربيه كانت الشمس
تتوسط المدينه اما طبعا اليوم فهو يعني جو
ممطر بشكل كبير يعني موسكو يمكنك العيش
فيها الفصول الاربعه يعني كما يتحدث
الاجانب في موسكو هو هناك شتاء ابيض وشتاء
اخضر لذلك طبعا الربيع هذه السنه جاء بشكل
متسارع ولعله الخير في رمضان نتمنى هذا
الشيء لذلك طبعا الشعب يتغير بشكل كبير مع
سطوع الشمس لا بد من لفت الانتباه بان
الشهر الاول من هذا العام شهري يناير شهد
شروق الشمس لساعات معدوده خلال الثلاثين
يوما اما شهر مارس وعلى غير عادته يعني
هناك ثلوج كثيره هناك درجات حراره يعني
تصل الى العشرين والثلاثين درجه تحت الصفر
اليوم في موسكو الحراره جيده بشكل كبير
وهذا ما ينعكس ويظهر بشكل كبير على وجوه
الروس والقائمه في المدينه رمضان كريم عبد
الجواد وكل عام وانت بالف خير شكرا جزيلا
لك من موسكو مراسل صباح العربيه عبد
المسائل العربيه عبد الجواد شكرا لك